prix nous allons retrouver tout de suite
et bien non quatre dessinateurs
je voulais dit le week-end prochain un
grand salon en salon international de la
bande dessinée qui va se dérouler à
angoulême pendant tout le week-end
prochain
et bien entendu je pense que les uns et
les autres vous israël voilà ce qui vous
serez là bas un certainement on y va
parce que c'est un problème important il
s'agit pour nous de défendre le droit
pour des dessinateurs de travailler pour
des adultes et de ne pas être assujettis
aux lois qui protègent la jeunesse
aucune raison que l'on considère les
journaux pour lequel on travaille comme
dangereux pour la jeunesse
c'est comme si on interdisait déjà lu m
parce qu'elles sont dangereuses pour la
jeunesse
l'enfant dans la bande dessinée ce sera
en quelque sorte le thème de ce salon
vous y sera aussi riser oui j'y serai
alors l'enfant dans la bande dessinée ça
vous a inspiré quoi quand on vous a
soumis le thème du salon au mieux comme
un prix prix comme ça à l'impôt mais
enfin je vais faire des dessins sont les
doigts j'en ai fait des quantités sur
les gosses déjà depuis des années on
mélange un peu plus c'est tout mais je
sais ça le thème de la bande dessinée
ces données le voici la voici le la
fiche de ce fils martin a si bien qu'à
but alors nous en sommes déjà à une
ébauche de deux mascottes possible de
dessin possible pour les jeux olympiques
ça vous a surpris vous qu'on choisisse
goofy oui parce que
parce qu'ils étaient il est étranger
alors on sait les étrangers on les aime
pas beaucoup
on avait bien pensé astérix mais astérix
bois de la potion magique alors il
paraît que ça incite au dopage
éventuellement bah oui mais vous savez
c'est peut-être ça maintenant l'emblème
non de le dire non vous êtes le seul
grand j à avoir maintenu les anneaux
olympiques dans votre audi
oui j'ai pris ce dessin pour accompagner
le coq de reiser alors nous allons les
découvrir si vous voulez les signes est
donc grand zèle voici cinq anneaux et sa
grappe de raisin ça c'est tout à fait
français
alors vous quelques explications quand
même quoi qu'on distingue bientôt vous
avez chargé là moi je propose mesrine
parce que c'est celui qui court le plus
vite
oui d'ailleurs il y avait un policier
tout à l'heure la qui ils courent pas
après mesrine
et puis il ya vous lâchez pas quoi
chercher un slogan pour vous ça viendra
peut-être alors il ya légitime défense
ah oui parce que lui il élimine tous ses
rivaux alors comme ça avant et 2 litres
au cent c'est assez champion du monde on
est quand même champions du monde ont
une spécialité dont quatre 4
propositions ici reaser alors là le coq
quand même si marcel lecoq
ça vient toutefois je comprends jamais
ce que je dessine moi ça me fait marrer
c'est tout à fait marrer je le dessine
comme ça peut pas mal j'ai vu de le
dessiner c'est rue et alors vous faut
dire aussi que non seulement vous êtes à
charlie hebdo mais vous êtes aussi à
l'humanité mon cher wolinski ce valérie
pourrait être le l'emblème français avec
son camembert et sa baguette
je le souhaite je pense t-elle vois pas
quel emblème le plus prestigieux on
pourrait avoir que le président lui-même
voilà en tout cas oui raizer voulait
ajouter le même les chinois c'est safari
relais chinois
merci pour ces suggestions et rendez
vous au salon international de la bande
dessinée à angoulême nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler le prochain
week-end tout de suite et bien un coup
d'oeil sur la bourse de paris
luc de molnar